we need to have that overly dramatic
things in our supermarket and what are
you buying oh there we go we have the
Kings 4 and opening and uh will Magnus
follow suit and snow he doesn't
and instead employees an opening called
the pack defense or maybe now the modern
yeah so Magnus he's not going for
anything solid he's not going for
anything calm here he's playing very
much in the spirit uh of his of his
strategy throughout the tour this season
provocative chess he's letting white
have the center he's just pushing pawns
only to the third rank or Black's third
Rank and he's letting white do what he
wants essentially Wesley stepping the
queen forward it looks like he's
prepared no pause most players would be
surprised by this but Magnus has been
employing this before remember white is
getting ready to Castle queenside throw
pawns forward towards the black king in
the center and we're gonna see fun we're
gonna see chaos in this game that's
almost guaranteed with this opening
Choice by Carlson and uh Magnus now
bringing his Knight to the center
black is just going to kind of curl up
into a ball very flexible for black you
can play on both sides of the board but
I don't know I don't like the strategy
I've seen Wesley punish too many people
yeah I mean we saw Wesley I mean I I've
seen him in a similar position like this
and he just said yeah I'll just played
my chessable course but uh intriguingly
we see that Magnus has actually played
this before he played this against Arjun
aragaisi yeah and uh and he was
successful there and he managed to work
well but
you don't win twice playing such risky
openings yeah it's lucky to win once
with playing such risky openings but
Magnus has done it several times
throughout the tour Wesley uh Kai you
mentioned looking out into at the Golden
Gate Bridge he was staring off for ages
before playing this move he was
eventually inspired the White Knight
came out and look at what it's set up
perfect centralization for white Knights
on the ideal squares Pawns in the middle
controlling everything again flexible
which way is the white king gonna go and
Magnus has to strike back you can't
continue playing passively as black
because at some point you will get
steamrolled whites Pawns in the center
will continue advancing forward and just
go for the black king
so how is Magnus going to react there's
two typical ways you can react here one
is to move the black dark squared Bishop
out finker to it on the G7 Square then
Castle the black king on that right side
but you do leave yourself as a sitting
Target Sitting Duck and White's going to
attack you if you commit the black king
the other strategy which Magnus prefers
is staying flexible with the black king
not telling the opponent which way he's
going to Castle and this move this queen
move highlights that this black queen
move as well stops white from advancing
in the center and blacks may be ready to
push some pawns on the Left Flank yeah
if the white king is the first to show
his intentions intriguing enough only
three games in my database and there's
actually someone with a name a Dutch
version of your name David Van huelingan
I love it I'm going to change my name
yeah
and uh how did van
he won he won yeah very good game yeah
and now now they're in New Territory
actually but then still similar this is
kind of a position that's been seen
before even though the exact move order
has not actually been played I mean the
ideas are very common why it simply just
develops the pieces waits for black to
react in the center or maybe take some
space in the wings and the white king
probably will go over to the right
yeah a few moves ago I thought Wesley
was going to be maybe a bit more
ambitious Castle off to the left then
start going straight really direct for
the black especially the black king but
Wesley's taken maybe a more traditional
classical approach as we call it just
happy to develop those white minor
pieces anyone who's new to chess anyone
watching who's just learned chess in the
last year or so look at white setup if
your opponent doesn't fight you in the
center these are the ideal squares for
your minor pieces the knights and
Bishops
and uh Wesley it sure he's showing even
the top players they follow the rules
yeah they follow conventional wisdom and
uh especially if your opponent is kind
of keeping you guessing you're not sure
what they're going to do um if there's
no tactics if there's no threats
captures no way to attack put your
pieces on good squares when the Center
opens later Wesley will be ready that is
his strategy at least and okay Magnus
not going for the idea of castling his
King yet not throwing any pawns on the
flanks forward he's just fighting
finally for the center
I think it's about time I think he
needed to do to do this sooner or later
Magnus before anything too bad happened
but uh now how is Wesley going to react
do you think he's going to Castle to the
right of anchor yeah I think he's going
to Castle I mean now that the pawn has
stepped forward though I think he might
take a time out to perhaps secure the
position of the dark squared Bishop yeah
um other moves that kind of spring to
mind
not really just castly in the king or
another thing is to expand on the left
side of the board push the a pawn two
squares yeah so you can advance on this
side it's just stopping Black from ever
pushing on this flank and now white
holds the key maybe on this left side of
the board uh he actually went for the
first plan you mentioned there Ivanka
and this is also very logical stopping
the Black Knight for example if you had
pushed on the side the Black Knight
could come and harass your bishop and
Bishops are key pieces in these
positions you don't want to lose your
dark Square Bishop with white you don't
want it to be traded off so that has
been prevented you mentioned this first
and also very natural and this is also
flexible because White's King could hint
at going this side still most likely as
you say it will go
um safely to the king side
and I'm expecting Magnus to try and rush
and do that too before the center
becomes open the one thing you don't
want to do is black is uh kind of
simplify it you don't want to clarify
the central tension because suddenly
firstly what's Bishop will be on a great
diagonal here but also the White Knight
could capture and suddenly white has a
nice Advanced Central Pawn as black this
Pawn is a bit of a weakness backward
Pawn can't really Advance can't really
challenge for the center so I think
Magnus uh yep he's going to get
developed there we go he moves his
Bishop he's finally ready to Castle
it's time for Wesley to decide do you go
to the right or do you go long do you go
Queen side
by the way he's going to reveal all
right this is the moment because if he
decides to not commit the king but you
know to just take some space on the left
side then that's still saying I'm gonna
Castle to the right yeah if you push
this Pawn you definitely won't Castle
this way anymore you've weakened
yourself on that flank so we're
expecting Wesley for example to Castle
kingside uh black will do the same and
from here we'll see some maneuvering
white might push some pawns white might
bring his Rooks to the center this is
pretty much the ideal setup for white
look how centralized these pieces are
and this is kind of what I was taught
when I was first learning the game just
put your piece on these squares and
nothing can ever go wrong
and that's what Wesley is most likely to
do he does Castle kingside we're going
to see a Karma game than we expected but
still looking
like there's a lot of tension looking
like a lot of life left definitely a lot
of life I mean the action will certainly
take place within the next 10 moves I
mean black has to break out he has to
find a way to develop a light squared
Bishop he has to see some space he has
to unbalance the white position
otherwise as you've pointed out totally
harmonious yeah
the black castles and we're expecting
either the white Rook to move into the
center or white maybe to stop any pawn
pushers on this Left Flank by pushing
his own Rooks Pawn very trendy
scanning maneuver yep
oh
and whilst the players are thinking you
know we're asking everyone what is your
favorite moment from the meltwater
Champions chess tour 2022 I mean so many
fun moments and Christopher Miller says
that prague's victory over evanchook for
some reason Springs to mind as a
memorable moment I remember evanchook
was there he he had him and then he
learned a slip in the last few seconds
and it was you know prague's reaction
and there we see the space gaining move
and uh Ian simcop says that uh David
Howell has to be the loveliest man in
chess we agree with you Ian it says a
happy birthday whenever it's time to
watch it all again in the studio it
warms our hearts too many great memories
to select one oh what a lovely message
yeah again and Pedro Ferreira says uh
shares with us a selfie saying learning
chess with laser beams right by Shaq 15.
oh yeah how cool that is very cool and
take a look at the picture as well I
quite I like these new versions of Chess
yeah that sounds like a lot of fun and
if you are around Shack 15 you can
probably see the players walking
to the arena or leaving the arena when
the day is finished
and meanwhile
um yeah a lot of action happening over
there in track 15 Magnus he's going for
moves that I condemned a move that I
thought he wouldn't go for at least not
now at least not in the foreseeable
future he has clarified the central
tension and normally it's black you want
a stronghold you need a pawn in this
four Central squares blacks Pawn which
previously stood on E5 though is traded
itself off and Magnus he's going to try
and activate as quickly as possible
after this capture because otherwise he
will get cramped he will be struggling
for the rest of the game so let's jump
in to show what has happened uh Wesley
has a decision to make black is just
captured a Pawn on this Square I'm not
sure which Way Wesley will recapture
taking with the Knight is maybe the more
normal way
um it's very tempting to capture with
the bishop too but magnus's idea is that
this Pawn is very strong long term but
short term could be a Target so magnus's
Knight might jump forward for example
and next move this Pawn is attacked
twice right now defended twice for
example if Wesley plays a bit too slowly
then Black's Rook can come as well and
three times this point now by the
knights and by the white uh by the Black
Brook and it's actually hard to defend
the only way to keep it defended would
be to step this Pawn forward but ugh you
don't want to do this as white because
suddenly your dark squares are very weak
around your king
so there's some small nuances here some
small details to check for Wesley so I
wouldn't be surprised if in the current
position he takes with the white Bishop
if we go back and uh there we go he does
capture with the bishop because now it's
easier for the white Rook to defend this
key Pawn in the center also Black's best
Bishop best minor piece in this types of
positions tend to be his dark Square
Bishop which protects the king and now
uh Wesley is ready for a potential trade
later on of those Bishops
who would you choose here Ivanka
I I like the white position I mean I'm a
big fan
plan you know just centralize the Rooks
and wait
for black to come up with an active plan
and ultimately the big dream is for
white to put pressure on the black D6
Pawn yeah this is this is a very poor
pawn and the problem is if you ever step
it forward as black if you have a
trade-off white might be happy to say
yes because suddenly after a capture
you're left with an isolony an isolated
Pawn in the middle of the board it's not
great it's a big weakness it's well
blockaded you'd never want this to
happen so yeah easy plan for the Rooks
to come to the Center for example if
black is slow say pushes a pawn and the
white Rook will slide across if black is
too slow again and then at some point
later white Bishop will move out the way
and already the White Queen and Rook are
lined up against this weakness
so yeah long term Magnus is in a bit of
trouble you need something short-term he
needs something something over the next
few moves and he tries that by launching
his Knight into the center
now there's a threat Knight takes Knight
would ruin the white Pawn structure and
uh this Black Knight if it's captured
suddenly would be replaced by a very
strong Pawn in the middle and if the
position locks up like this it will be
level
Magnus will have solved his problems I
think Wesley's plan or what he's got to
do is move his Knight out the way move
his Knight I'm not sure where for
example you could Retreat and get ready
to join uh throw even more pawns for it
in the center of the board some
calculation needs to be done here but if
you can achieve this kick the Black
Knight away
maybe some chances of an advantage what
do you think yeah I like the idea it
actually wasn't the first move that kind
of sprung to mind because I would have
been like oh preserve the light squared
Bishop but it's a very nice idea
actually that just to ignore that and
just go well hang on a second let me
just control the center let me just take
all the space with my pawns yeah so uh I
mean that's the plan I was attracted to
um it feels like role reversal now
you're protective of your Bishops I'm
pushing pawns it's like we've sort
places it happened but yeah as you
mentioned the other key move here the
other move that Wesley will consider is
dropping the bishop back keeping it and
a nitrate actually doesn't solve the
problem of Black's backward Pawn no it's
actually even more vulnerable if
anything on this open file
if white gets the time
so Magnus trying to trade pieces trying
to equalize as black but he's still a
few moves away what do you think Wesley
would do if he's going to go for your
idea it's a bit safer than mine
retreating this bishop protecting the
Knight opens the D file as well
um it's more of a Wesley type of move
yeah he's very known for
having great intuition right knowing
where to place the pieces basically yeah
we talk about just knowing where the
pieces go it's I think it's just partly
pattern recognition but partly
um it's just sensing coordination as
well every piece seems to protect each
other when Wesley plays he he goes for
your move as we predicted
um yeah everything protects each other
everything is harmonious everything is
where it should be no weaknesses no bad
Pawn structures none of that long-term
stuff that we talk about it just feels
so smooth
feels like there's a plan for move one
till the end of the game with Wesley and
that's rare very few players in the
history of chess
I've mastered that skill and yeah
magnus's may be another one who when he
wants to control the game and not take
any risks he's got a similar style to
Wesley but Magnus may be a bit more
Universal a bit more uh well ambitious
with his approach
and okay we do see Magnus gain space
block things up on the left but slow I
pointed this out again as a very slow
approach
and meanwhile we hear some noises what's
what's happening here
I don't know what's happening yeah
wow sounds intriguing already
looking forward to that game being
released causing some drama yeah all
right well the game is going on Magnus
Carlsen is in his uh 13th move the bars
over to Wesley so side this is the tour
finals of uh what's been a revolutionary
season on the meltwater Champions
Chester three Majors three of uh the
tournaments have been on site with a
bunch of players this is the first
hybrid one with four players in San
Francisco and four players in their
homes around the world so I'm excited to
hear from tour director Arnold what is
the thought behind this hybrid event
Tanya
Kaya truly a revolutionary season the
talk continues to grow and expand and
the one man behind the success of it all
we've got him with us it is tour
director Arne it must be so special to
see the final shape up in the city of
San Francisco it's fantastic to finally
be here in San Francisco and have the
final event what an amazing season we've
had with the fact that we are at the
last tournament now of the 2022 season
and the fact that we're actually in San
Francisco doing it here at check that
that's really cool very cool I want to
ask you this is a unique event because
you've got four players on site and four
playing remotely why is that the case
well that is kind of the Beauty with
this entire concept that we are able
when you're doing online tournaments
like this that players can play from
wherever so we can have all players
gathered at one event we can all players
gathered remotely or we can do here we
could have a really cool venue here for
some of the players and then some of the
players participating from home
one of the big visions of the tour has
been to transform chess into an Esports
and do you feel you've been able to
achieve that we have come a very far way
uh the goal is still we are just raising
the bar we are not crossing the goal
line by far we're racing the bar and
continuing to Innovation we're going to
continue to do that as well
and one of the big moments for the tour
was also when it received the Digital
entertainment award that was a big deal
that was that was really amazing to have
that leaders in sports awards and the
fact that we are now only in our second
season acknowledge like Wimbledon like
NBA that we are up on that level that's
that's thanks to our Incredible Crew and
fantastic partners and of course I'm
really talented chess players very
talented chess bears but aren't they the
one time when the tour really made it
into big headlines happened at the
Julius bear generation cup when a Magnus
refused to play against Hans after that
Hans went on to sue pretty much went on
to at least uh file a lawsuit to pretty
much everyone we haven't heard anything
since then what are the developments
what can you tell us
well that's with the lawyers and uh for
now it's uh that's a good place for it
to be and let's see how this develops
we're all waiting to hear on that but
the question I want to ask you as a tour
director and I think a lot of our fans
want to know about this is there a
future where hands will be invited back
on the tour
this is the last C last tournament of
this season and like from the first to
the second season we did a lot of
improvements involvements and changes so
we are still working on how the next
season is going to be and there's a lot
of still a lot of balls in the air also
when it comes to the potential fact that
just come and play Magnus group might be
a common entity in the next season so uh
it's uh depending on how things plays
out actually that's actually big news in
the Chess World with chesscom taking
over and what does that mean for the
future of the tour in 2023
that's going to be really really really
exciting it open UPS even more exciting
opportunities so we are looking forward
to hopefully see that this uh deal is
closed and we can all work together
thank you thank you
future is super exciting hopefully the
future is bright especially for the male
torture Champions just for season three
of the tour is coming up probably will
start in February
2023. this is the end to the 2022 season
day one of the tour finals Wesley so
with the white pieces here in game two
against Magnus Carlsen what a start to
the tournament with these two facing off
in the very first match up the bar is
over to Wesley's side in this game two
first game was a draw you think Wesley
will win this yeah I mean there's
exciting times in the Chess World for
the tour but also exciting times ahead I
think in this game for Wesley so because
look at the White Queen she's just
already planted herself entrenched
herself near the black king that black
king is not safe with all those dark
Square weaknesses around it White's
Knights of ready to pounce whites Rook
on that open file it just looks
beautiful for Wesley still no threat
still no follow-up but Ivanka I mean I'm
worried for Magnus Carlson in this game
because how does black defend I'm also
incredibly worried because
um I have to say when I played Fabiana
Carana in some in a classical game
Colette the queen get to that square and
I was like well it doesn't do anything
let's just play around it and let's
focus on the center just like Magnus is
doing and the one piece of advice that
Fabi gave me after the game was said you
played great but you should have kicked
away my queen don't let that Queen sit
there happily and uh I don't know why
Magnus is voluntarily gone for this
because like you say
Wesley within the next few movies is
going to be primed to strike you know
the White Knight is getting ready to
spring forward pawns are going to be
launched towards the black king danger
is brewing yep that's the Knight can
join the White Queen in the attack it
looks almost deadly for example if the
black Bishop moves and there's many
problems here firstly the White Queen
could even step back and we could Target
this Pawn again we mentioned that that
was a potential idea earlier in the game
it still exists uh the White Knight for
example if the black Mission moves could
spring forward and this is the idea you
mentioned Ivanka this Pawn is protected
for now but that's the thing it's only
temporarily guarded by this Black Knight
sorry this Black Knight but if the Black
Knight does disappear if it's kicked
away game over the White Queen is going
to capture this pawn and it's going to
be Checkmate within a few moves uh the
black king is just too weak and you can
kick away that black knight first by
kicking away its fellow this Knight is
actually trapped in the center of the
wood and uh for example if let's say
black waist is a move the whole idea
will be to eliminate this Knight at all
costs you could step forward with your
Pawn in the center you could even step
forward with this Pawn open up the white
Rook on the f file this Rook looks like
it's doing nothing in the current
position in the game but it's two or
three moves away from becoming open and
let's go back because Magnus trying to
deal with the potential Brewing attack
by trading off pieces that's good chess
wisdom in general trade-off pieces if
you know you're about to come under Fire
especially your king now white tonight
can't join the attack anytime soon but
the other problems persist especially
this Pawn white is threatening at some
point to come back and just win this
Pawn it's too weak uh the white Brooks
could double up double up on the defile
white could step forward with one of
them Slide the other one behind and go
off to this weakness
just don't see how you can deal with
this for example if your Bishop moves
you already lose a pawn your Bishop
needs to develop eventually but the
White Queen just slides back double
attack hitting the Knight which is loose
undefended hitting this Pawn which is
now overwhelmed
it's really scary for the world champion
uh it looks like Wesley's just played a
great game so far continuing his good
form from the global championship
um how do you I mean how do you even
react if you can't develop this bishop
it means you can't develop your rook in
the corner
yeah the black queen is misplaced as
well the Black Knight ends up stepping
back but away from its own King away
from the protection of the king side it
wants to come into the center to replace
the Knight that was just traded off
ah you know I mean it looks like a
temporary measure it just feels all
wrong instinctively feels like black is
playing with only his Knight only his
Rook the black queen is just miles away
from the defense
I mean what is that night doing I mean
yeah I know it's going to jump into the
center but uh say the light Square
Bishop moves well it's gonna get kicked
away again yeah for example if you just
step your Rook up this was the other
plan just to double up against the
center as you mentioned the White Knight
attacks the bishop so what just Retreats
and you're getting ready to even win
some time against the Black Knight and
you just can't chase away the thorn and
black side the queen
and combined with weak Pawn I had a
significant Advantage I don't say
winning it doesn't quite feel like it's
winning but it feels like within the
next few moves okay he Retreats the
queen I thought that this wasn't
necessarily the best move
going for material yeah he wants to win
this Pawn immediately Wesley so
recruiting the queen and Magnus reacts
by counter-attacking
this is literally the only undefended
point in White's Camp the only
undefended pawn and uh what is the idea
here so for example if the pawn steps up
still looks very tempting here and the
pawn does indeed step up to a guarded
Square now I guess black wants to bring
his Queen forward and keep some pressure
on this Knight so White Queen is kept
honest tied down to the defense of its
Knight either this Square by Magnus or
maybe the square to to attack this piece
I like your first move because I feel
like the Knight should jump to the C5
Square okay yeah keep this one and he
does play that keep the square available
for Black's night
it's still hanging by a thread for
Magnus but at least he's guarded
everything for now
yeah I agree with you America I don't
like white Queen retreating I think she
was more active where she previously
stood
let's go back to the players Wesley can
he amp up the pressure can he just hold
together his whole left side of the
board the night the pawns if he can he's
gonna win upon he's going to win the
game
seven minutes against five as well
I mean this opening experiment for
Magnus I think it's just too much
I don't think he can get away with doing
this against Wesley game after game
and uh yeah it's it's hard to be I try
not to be too harsh but
yeah it just feels like he hasn't had a
chance Magnus Wesley's just played a
great opening yeah I
don't even think he's going to get away
with it I think he's going to get
punished
and white just has a very comfortable
position I mean there's even if white
were to do absolutely nothing Black's
problems are permanent yeah it's going
to persist you know he can even just
kind of push the Jeep on one square
forward move the Queen Bishop to a
safety square and then just get on with
okay and there we see Wesley initiate a
tree sorry a queen trade yeah it makes
some sense Black's Queen was the only
active piece so why not try and trade
her off get rid of her Black's d-pawn
that we've been talking about a lot
still a weakness a permanent weakness
essentially but the evaluation bar
doesn't like it and Black's Knight does
Leap Forward so the problem for white is
if you trade off the queens now it's on
blacks terms and blacks porn will
recapture the queen
attacking the white knight kicking the
White Knight away and black now is
aiming for white Central Pawn
uh yeah makes a lot of sense what Magnus
has just done Wesley needs to trade off
the Queens but
in favorable circumstances he needs to
maybe activate the other white Rook the
other white Rook can defend the pawn in
the center there's no rush to get rid of
those pieces to head towards that end
game yet
only when you're ready Wesley that is
the key and he's taking his time he's
still minute up on the clock that was
the key to Wesley winning the global
Chess Championship he was always ahead
on time it seemed and all of those
knockout phases when he was defeating
the likes of Hikaru Nakamura Nihao sarin
all these great speed players
Wesley is so practical very rarely in
time pressure
and so I'm expecting him just to sit
tight not commit not trade off any
Queens yet
it's in Wesley's style as well you know
just over protect his pieces and then
only strike when the iron is hot and I
agree I agree with you guys I find it
I'm like struggling to think of an
active plant for Magnus because I've
because magnus's position has so as this
one terrible Pawn weakness he has to
like liven up the odds somehow and they
Wesley takes a step back with the queen
weird very weird expect that one I
thought he would just play you suggested
I mean it's not just the fact that this
queen now has parked herself opposite
the black Rook which is never really
advised but it's also the fact that the
White Queen could have gone to this
Square two moves ago and he could have
saved a move essentially he's lost a
Tempo with his Queen and if you lose a
Tempo in chess even if you've got a
fantastic position often there could be
consequences uh it's all about timing
every move counts
why Retreat the queen like this why
bring her forward when you could have
gone to the square originally
strange I guess there is an attack
White's Rook has opened up now on the D
file on that open Line attacking blacks
backward D Pawn
but suddenly maybe Magnus has some
active possibilities to do with the
White Queen sitting on this vulnerable
file that e-file is not a safe haven for
her no
what a view on the cameras by the way
it's very very important isn't it it
could be a picture you know we talk a
lot about nfts but I feel like this is
the picture I would like to have on my
wall two players deep in thought with
that view
and
it's actually quite inspirational when
you play in such magnificent
surroundings because often when you're
struggling and you need that dose of
inspiration you just look outside and
you think Life is Beautiful yeah I'm so
lucky to be here playing in this
wonderful location
and then you look back at the position
and you're like oh
it's not that bad after all well that's
that's what I think unless your Magnus
and your position is pretty bad
are you all right it's uh even this
position I mean Magnus has his problems
I mean primarily that D6 Pawn but his
black queen is active
yeah and there's still some counter play
I don't think Wesley has an immediate
threat actually so he has the time to
develop a piece say for instance yeah
maybe just move this bishop out for
example you can move into this square
and the whole idea is if White's Rook
does take your Pawn right now maybe the
Black Knight could jump out the way I'm
not sure where it goes though take a
pawn yeah I mean you could take a pawn
the problem is now yes The Rook is
attacked but it could potentially give
itself up for the bishop this gets very
complicated suddenly give itself up for
the bishop and next move you take the
Black Knight and uh we might get a
situation like this where white has two
pieces against a black rook and a couple
of Pawns very tense and wow Wesley's
sacrifices Rook suddenly drama on the
board let's go back to the game Magnus
pushed upon taking advantage of the fact
this Pawn is pinned in the center the
black the white porn cannot capture but
Wesley gave up his Rook giving up a rook
and the whole idea is suddenly if the
Rook is captured black would walk into a
fork the queen is attacked she only has
one safe School where and suddenly this
looks deadly a deadly check White's
night coming in for the kill coming into
the attack but Magnus reacted instantly
of course he didn't take this Rook he
had foreseen this trick and he gives up
his Knight what a weird move uh what a
hard move to spot but it looks quite as
strong for black suddenly the whole
reason is uh if this Knight is captured
now then after Pawn takes Rook suddenly
the black queen is no longer trapped she
can swoop back and defend this key
Square no checks for the White Knight
still looks scary I've got to say those
black squares those dark squares around
the black king
really really weak white can't quite
build an attack on these squares though
everything is protected so in the
current position what is happening black
is just taking a pawn suddenly there's
two threats firstly you're attacking
this Knight secondly you're attacking
this Rook
how can Wesley guard against both of
those had he missed this move maybe he's
going to be shocked and unable to react
uh
seems shocked to be honest I don't think
he anticipated that Magnus had seen this
crafty blow especially as the world
champion just reacted instantaneously
and I do think that he has to bite the
bullet and just go into that line
because otherwise if you just Retreats
The Rook to defend the Knight then it
does feel like black has gotten away
with it you know after the trades where
is Black's advantage
not there anymore I mean if anything
like you say anyone is better it's black
black simply brings the bishop out
suddenly this Pawn might be dangerous
long term it will start running
um yeah if the knights come off the
board if white can't attack now then
black is better so uh the evaluation bar
might say it's slightly in White's favor
but that's only if Wesley finds all the
best moves if he retreats
Magnus it's momentum Magnus and uh yeah
I think you'll write your Banker just
give up this Rook just leave it up for
grabs in the center of the board it's
kind of poisoned in a way and if we do
see that variation at least now you get
an all-powerful night and octo Knight as
you call it with its tentacles all over
the dark squares and um yeah I think
this has to be the acid test of magnus's
sacrifice his idea and uh okay this is
the current position it's chaos
life in this game and uh it's gonna take
us a while to figure out but Wesley does
go for this with three minutes left on
the clock each uh so we do see this
critical position let's do a count black
is up material a rook for a knight and a
pawn so black is up five points against
four points he's up one point on the
board but it's the quality of pieces
that counts and the Knight is the best
piece
so can he get it he needs it into the
square but the black queen defends first
he lines up threatening a discovered
attack against the black queen
oh the valuation bar going down yeah the
evaluation we bar didn't like that at
all and uh one thing that I learned
this weekend is that a night is not
necessarily better than a rook in fact
most of the time The Rook beats the
knights in fact three times out of three
yeah I had three games in a row where
you had this material balance yeah I
mean what are the chances and now we're
seeing it here in a game that I'm
commenting on the universe is trying to
tell me something study your material
imbalances yeah Rick versus knights in
some positions then I can dominate this
is one situation where it has the
potential to dominate but Wesley's
shaking his head suddenly
he's retreating his Bishop he's getting
ready to kick back the black queen with
a pawn we mentioned the F Pawn pushing
forward earlier gaining space
whatever that is by the way that the
players are treated to this is basically
a POV like a point of view what Magnus
and Wesley can see right now out the
window and uh okay suddenly the black
queen is kicked away but she's gone to a
very active Square deep in the white
camp
I mean it's just chaos on the board
white tonight has to jump before it's
captured yeah if the white knight is
captured Magnus will win the bar went
opposite
for a moment
Agnes in big trouble
he was in bigger trouble I think he's
out of the worst but he has to give back
some material this White Knight has
delivered a fork Wesley look at how much
he's shaking his head he knows he's not
in that much trouble with white but he
knows he was probably winning or had a
massive Advantage earlier suddenly after
the White Knight has to catch one of the
black Rooks it has to make a choice uh
we will see level material again but
black has a two versus one Pawn
advantage on the queen side left on the
Left Flank looks pretty strong
potentially long term it certainly does
and the night taking the rook in the
corner but still
for the time being there is some danger
for Magnus I mean especially because the
king is unguarded so I'm thinking you
know maybe it's possible for Wesley to
push the F Pawn forward just to seize as
much space as possible because as
David's highlighted there is some
potential danger yeah if the queens and
Rooks disappear black is almost winning
in the end game if it's just Bishops and
pawns on the board so Wesley has to go
forward I think you're right Ivanka f
for Ford push the F Pawn go for the
attack if you stop pedaling you'll fall
off your bike uh it's one of those types
of positions and Wesley shaking his head
momentum against him go for it Wesley
push the F Pawn forward we need to see
some action and drama the position
demands it another potential move would
be to mobilize The Rook get it into the
seventh row but I always prefer my Pawn
fishes yeah go for some important pushes
Black's Queen is on such a good Square
she's keeping an eye on White's Rook
Bishop also she's eyeing up White's
remaining Pawn that white a Pawn on the
queen side
if that one Falls it's trouble so you
have to seize the moment he does go
forward it's still getting spicy on the
board
I'm expecting Magnus to move his Bishop
there we go you didn't want to touch
that white Pawn that advanced if you
captured that pawn you would have only
opened up the black king and now there's
a trick on the board if White's Bishop
is deflected away then it's Rook will
fall so you cannot capture the black
Bishop it's poisoned
two minutes now for Wesley I said he is
very good at avoiding time trouble but
he is on the brink now on the clock you
have to be quick you have to be
resourceful now and you have to up the
pace and this this is always the time
where Magnus is in his element
is when the clocks
clocks the last seconds Magnus and
especially the younger players they play
incredibly accurately with good
instincts and uh Magnus
well he has a big threat on the board so
I'm expecting Wesley just to move the
bishop and he moves it one step forward
and now this is the big question should
Magnus take some time out to protect his
king or does he get greedy yeah he can
get greedy blacks Queen can go and win
the white a pawn
has no protection
the White Queen can go back where she
came from she can swoop in again the
black king is vulnerable in the back
rank as well White's Pawn the F Pawn if
it steps forward to F6
sets up a meeting net but Magnus does
activate his Rook this is classic Magnus
all the pieces in the Party part of the
evaluation bar hates it and suddenly can
Wesley strike can Wesley attack while
the iron is hot go for that black king I
mean yeah it has to be an attack
otherwise the evaluation bar would not
react long term black is doing great
to be a short-term measure yeah
definitely I'm just thinking you know
push the F Pawn forward trap the king
massive threat on the board as you say
trap the king there's a Checkmate in two
threat if Wesley can get his Queen back
where it came from it's going to slide
into G7 and that is mate no way to stop
that
I mean how do you stop it now uh if the
White Queen gets in it's deadly for
example if you move your king this is
one way to try and stop the queen coming
in this doesn't work either because
White's Rook will come and deflect the
black Rook away and uh if the Black
Brook moves suddenly Checkmate again
how do you stop this if you're Magnus
Carlsen deadly threat on the board oh
yeah
yeah Queen slide her one square to
attack the F Pawn but this isn't that
satisfactory either because white can
simply push forward the E Pawn and say
you cannot capture that because of
potential backhat rank issues yeah back
rank issues uh this Pawn on F6 if you
could ever get it to there in a real
game you're destined to get a big attack
and the black king here will be trapped
and look at the stopfish suggestions the
computer says there's only one move for
Magnus to survive and uh limit the
damage and that is to slide the queen
back for a queen exchange that is not
obvious at all though the whole idea is
you're threatening a queen exchange if
the White Queen he finds it though
Magnus Carlsen if the White Queen moves
now then there is a cunning check
hitting the white king and you're just
in time to capture this white Pawn
eliminate all the danger but Wesley of
course spots that geometric Motif and he
does protect his Pawn he keeps the
Queens on the board a queen exchange
favors back remember and now the pawn is
protected wow he survives Magnus I would
not have been sure about that and even
now stockfish look at it it says there's
still only one or two moves to survive
and they're not obvious but Magnus does
again find the best move he pushes this
point forward it looks like a big
blunder of course if you take this Pawn
however this check Saves the Day check
and black swoops back just in time to
defend with the queen
and uh yeah still it's uh Lively Ivanka
and the white Pawn stepping forward this
is an idea you mentioned clamping down
these two squares now the threat exists
but I guess the black king can swoop to
the defense and uh guard everything yes
the only move but it's sufficient it's
enough to hold the position and it's
such a nice classy move this uh Pawn H6
yeah this Pawn push that he pushed
earlier just to cover dance squares you
can cover weaknesses with pieces or you
can cover them with pawns and what is
Magnus thinking about here he surely
needs to defend this Pawn before it's
too late
let's go back to the players one and a
half minutes for Wesley so under one
minute for Magnus Carlson
who would you take care of your Banker
just because you know he has an
initiative he has the momentum and
there's still a lot of margin for of
error for Magnus
and uh the white book is still kind of
come to the seventh row
maybe not bow is the time now definitely
is the time
um
actually the more I look at it the more
I thinking about
Magnus is in real trouble Wesley has
good chances to turn this around into a
win yeah very very good chances and
Magnus needs to continue defending super
accurately just to survive so now
there's maybe a small threat of White's
root just going to take the black bee
Pawn protected by the white Bishop
um the black Bishop does guard the poor
nearer of the black kings so you're okay
on the king side for now but
yeah you have to be 100 sure that
everything is protected Magnus under 30
seconds how do you keep a position like
this one intact he pushes a B Pawn very
calm he's trying to distract white
distract Wesley so's attack against the
black king by playing on the other flank
but the black king is still bereft of
any protection all you need is to
introduce another piece into the attack
I'm not sure whether that's the white
Bishop right now I don't see any direct
way in
um you could just exchange a set of
Pawns on this left Left Flank but Magnus
he's trying and Wesley's not
got too much time either so it doesn't
and I'm thinking that his position
actually Demands a Sacrifice or maybe
there he go he's building it up and the
whole idea is the bishop will come and
capture the pawn on G6 King is forced
out into the open yeah if this happens
this would destroy the black shelter for
example pontex porn and this is a
winning tactic right Ivanka Bishop takes
porn as you say and there's a pin along
this fight along this fire rank sorry
the pawn can't capture King takes would
end in Checkmate in a couple of moves
this is the key checkmating pattern and
uh Magnus wow it was so calm so
collected he tries to prevent prevent
this by dropping his Bishop back and uh
in this position it doesn't stop the
idea if Bishop takes Pawn but after the
king is forced out into the open there's
no good available checks for white the
White Queen can't check from this Square
because it's covered by the bishop and
he can't check from this Square because
it's covered from afar by The Black
Queen
hanging by a thread but uh looks like
he's surviving Magnus and Wesley he's
really upping the pressure creating a
threat on every move
hitting the Black Brook yeah Rook takes
Rook would allow white to come through
and make a new Queen you can't allow
that so that one's off the agenda I mean
but also Magnus will be thinking about
every potential sacrifice here so saving
moves a rook to some random Place far
away then you do even have possibilities
of oh he's captured the work wow you can
do this
given up he's given white a very strong
past Pawn but he's gonna swoop back and
defend against it he's given a check and
when the white king moves oh look at the
bar for the first time in the tour
finals huge reactions huge reaction but
why why is the evaluation bar showing
such a big Advantage for white because
suddenly The Black Queen it has come
back and defended this Pawn
wow the other Pawn's just running
through is this the idea is Wesley just
going to make a new Queen with his other
Pawn
the evaluation bar going down slightly
but after Queen takes Pawn right now
Magnus has to eliminate this very strong
Pawn uh there's another passport on the
radar two squares away
I think you're right with that reaction
Kyle because this is going to be a new
Queen on the board wow how do you stop
it Magnus is trying to make a new queen
of his own but he's slower in the race
black needs three moves white only needs
two uh just push the pawn Wesley you're
running through
crown that pawn push it forward to Glory
this looks winning for white white is
closer in the race
yeah what a game so far I mean and uh
there you go Queen has to defend against
the B Pawn and uh Wesley plays such a
chill move drops the queen back and
keeps an eye on the a Pawn Yeah and uh
Magnus is stuck the black queen is fixed
permanently guarding against just the
porn Queen's the worst blockaders they
want to be active they don't want to be
defending
wow this is so calm from Wesley he's
trying to trap trying to trick Magnus if
the black queen takes the white Pawn in
the center of the board the white
Queen's gonna sweep back where she came
from and a queen exchange will help the
white porn run through so Magnus he's
locking down the white king
the question is can Wesley swoop in
offer a queen exchange again
almost winning at this point
the only thing you have to guard against
is that the black queen will come down
to the ce1 square and threaten a
Perpetual check if you keep that covered
you have if you have a safe home for the
white king Wesley is 100 winning nothing
Magnus can do you think Wesley is going
to go on a bit of a king walk start
moving the white king towards the center
because it's a bit trapped it's a bit
boxed in right now okay he drops back
that's very classy nice from Wesley he's
threatening to promote his poor now that
white bee Pawn is about to become a new
Queen I was going to say the black queen
had to blockade that pawn but nope uh
Magnus locks the white Queen's vision
evaluation bar continues to go up nearly
plus six now for white that means
there's a direct win but where is it and
10 seconds left for Wesley Seoul
and he win this
and the nice flashy moves continue uh
look at that he's saying hey why don't
you take off my bishop and allow me a
queen and uh Magnus of course Can't Go
For That
okay evaluation part really confusing
though dropping slightly for Wesley
there was again a trick if White had
captured the black Bishop black would
have had time to eliminate that very
dangerous white porn so you could not
allow that oh the advantage disappearing
is Magnus in time to trade off the
Bishops and soon start running with that
black apron that black pawn is going to
distract the White Queen away
is Magnus out of danger
it looks that way yeah he's just in time
that black porn is really dangerous now
yeah and that man the White Queen just
cannot mobilize herself you know she
cannot let go of the defense of the E5
pawn and that's why Wesley pushes his G
Pawn forward but it's not enough yeah
it's not enough and Magnus ignores
everything on the other flank he's just
pushing this black a pawn forward and
White Queen is overworked she wants to
perform two jobs she wants to help her
own porn run through but she has to stop
the black pun she can't do both at the
same time
Black's Pawn on the a-file White's Pawn
on the b-file they're gonna get traded
off by hook or by Crook and we will see
the game fizzle out towards a draw after
all that drama Wesley was one or two
moves away yeah
so close but Magnus defending that's why
he's so good so hard to beat license
quite incredible defense actually from
Magnus I mean I thought it was all over
and we see Wesley shaking his head and
he looks away now he knows the position
is no more than a draw now he's let it
slip yeah no way forward you've run out
of ammunition you need to keep the
Bishops on the board I think that was
his big mistake trading off those
Bishops otherwise he was simply winning
but uh yeah Magnus we have to give
credit to him for surviving that's all
you can do essentially in situations
like that just try to survive
and four seconds three seconds for
Wesley oh
I thought we put one second left wow
playing on the edge and he's given up a
pawn could Magnus try to win this game
now uh it doesn't look possible but
suddenly the white king is very open
lots of tracks on the on the cards
mostly shaking his head
yeah it's time to just liquidate this
Pawn distracts the White Queen remember
and now a check if anyone can win it's
only black white has really ugly doubled
H pawns black has a past F Pawn this one
of course should be a draw
Queen end game level pawns but Magnus
looks still pretty determined I was
gonna ask that do you think Magnus will
kind of go well you know I was lucky to
to survive this so I'll be happy with
the draw or will he now play for the win
he grind it out like The Grandmaster he
is I think he's going to try and grind
it out Magnus uh these top players are
very in in tune with the momentum in
every game and
he survived the worst Magnus and look at
the evaluation bars inching slowly in
Black's favor for the first time ever
and uh yeah there's no risk for black
worst comes to worst it's a Perpetual
track or a queen exchange and a drawn
porn end game
so why not try to squeeze this one out
white king is more vulnerable in Queen
end games that's very relevant factor
and also Magnus can just
can just by giving as many checks as
possible and there you go puts his Queen
in the center attacking one weak born
yeah it's
difficult one to uh defend actually
because you don't want to be trading off
Queens absolutely not those doubled H
pawns are useless you have to trade off
Queens in the right way and maybe that's
what Wesley so is going for right now
the White Queen can come back on the
diagonal plant herself next to the black
queen defend everything but
yeah it's definitely Wesley on the
defense there we go and now a queen
exchange would if black takes this coin
would improve the white Pawn structure
after White recaptures
so uh Magnus says no it's going to be on
my terms and now the black F Pawn could
start pushing
Magnus turning the screw
trying to
kind of squeeze blood out of a stone
here he gives a check black skin coming
forward no good checks for white now
and now your idea of pushing the F Pawn
that's going to come into operation I
mean where is the queen going to go
she's gonna have to retreat all the way
back and uh there Wesley oh he must be
in such a bad mood now because he would
have been thinking in the past you'll be
thinking about all those missed
opportunities whereas Magnus he's living
in the present he's enjoying his moment
yeah Wesley has to forget the ghosts of
the previous uh of the previous moves of
that winning middle game the winning end
game he had
and uh both sides looking super focused
this is a great lesson again for
everyone at home even when things have
gone wrong you have to keep focused
otherwise you might lose the whole point
and Wesley he's made that switch to
playing for the draw quite well so far
he's actually threatening Checkmate
black gives a check now but White Queen
if he gets one more move slides into the
corner h8 that's black king is trapped
so uh Magnus might not have enough time
now to make progress he has to defend
against that threat give all the checks
you want as black
but you have to defend against White's
Queen
and okay centralization also important
in Queen name games Queens dominate they
control most squares from the center of
the board and uh this is a nice Square
to as it controls the h8 square and
I I would give a few more checks yeah
it's hard to make progress the problem
for black is you can't Advance your king
the worst move on the board now would be
moving the black king forward because
the White Queen slides behind checkmate
can't move the king you're playing just
with the queen okay
trying to bully Wesley trying to force
his Queen out of the way with the queen
Exchange
I don't think you can exchange the pawn
structure does favor Black and the king
and porn end game you don't even want to
go there don't calculate these whites
has much better chances of saving the
game when the Queens remain on the board
I would just slide the queen over to the
d8 square and uh again Ask black how are
you going to progress and Wesley does do
that yep this is nice uh I love the
square that Wesley chose that you
suggested just because it defends
White's pawns uh from afar it threatens
potentially some tracks
and uh yeah it's going to be very hard
for Magnus to win this one it feels like
it should be a draw with best play it
will be a draw most likely but
another lesson for everyone at home just
keep playing you might occasionally
squeeze out those extra half points here
and there
and this would be a huge turnaround if
Magnus can indeed find a way past
Wesley's defenses I have to say if
Magnus were to turn this around and be
winning it would be one of those
situations where you look at your
opponent and you go I really hate you
I don't know you don't often do that
even if you're being crushed you'd often
don't have those thoughts but in this
situation it would be yeah gotta hate
your opponents sometimes
that's cruel that's cold-blooded but uh
yeah Wesley's doing fine he's holding
yeah we all know chassis cruel though
sometimes you anchor so will we see that
scenario Black's King is going back and
he checks now on the seventh Rank by
White Queen would be blocked by Black's
Queen going back again offering that
coin exchange
um I'm expecting Magnus now to block
there we go and Wesley will continue
saying no to a queen exchange while he
has these bad double Pawns
to each pawns are not necessarily better
than one and a repetition of the
position potentially by Wesley he's
saying to Magnus you're not getting
anywhere uh my queen controls everything
I think we might well see Magnus give up
his winning attempts soon because it's
very hard to make progress without
weakening uh exposing the black king
so in hindsight you'd actually think
that maybe black rushed with pushing the
F Pawn
should have done it one square at a time
could have
20s and then pushed his Pawn exactly
now that is an art form yeah it's an
Artful Magnus we know is the ultimate
grinder but unfortunately when you're up
against a great defender like Wesley
oh but hang on a second Wesley is taking
some risk because he's marching forward
with his King
yeah so Black's Queen could go and grab
a Pawn on the third rank but then
White's Queen could just deliver uh
checks Forever The Black Queen has to
act as a Defender so you're right I
wouldn't dream of this movie if Uncle
the king is so so open there for white
but no way to punish it no way to take
advantage for Magnus
that must be frustrating
and okay diagonal checks often a good
idea in Queen end games I'm not sure
what this achieves exactly if White's
King just retreats
which it most likely will
don't play with fire here don't continue
advancing that white king uh I mean
maybe you can get away with it maybe
that's what Magnus uh Wesley will do but
no the safer
option is to retreat
you have everything under control
let's give him some more tracks
his dream is to capture one of the white
pawns with check
I don't think you can get away with it
you can you can't quite orchestrate that
and the key is going to the side
the problem for black is that he just
can't mobilize his King maybe maybe he
can having said that maybe he can go on
an Epic Journey you know the Czechs
haven't worked out so okay he gives
another check King will take a step back
yeah and then what next that's the big
problem
porn
yeah I know now now the king is rolling
in it's coming we're gonna be here for a
long time ladies and gentlemen we are
okay he's not giving up his winning
attempts well the next few games they're
starting in only three minutes we're
gonna follow Mama diarov against
pragnananda Prague will have the white
pieces in game three starting in only
two minutes and uh he cannot lose that
game Prague mom Daryl is up by one point
and if he wins game three he will win
the match we will jump into that game
when this one finishes sometime in the
near future when was the last Pawn push
uh David oh that's a very good question
Ivanka 63 I think okay so 63 plus 50 is
113 so still a long way to go before the
50 move rule kicks into effect
so that's the no progress rule it means
if black cannot exchange or capture a
piece or push a pawn in 50 moves no
progress has been made
it feels like he hasn't made much
progress but uh
he will keep trying Magnus Wesley's
found another nice centralizing check
and uh yeah Magnus still looks super
focused he looks determined to press
this one to squeeze every bit of life
out of this end game but
still not easy okay he offers another
queen exchange again Wesley shuts the
door and says no I like this move
blocking Black's pawns if you can
maintain this setup if you can continue
blocking blocking Black's pawns forever
the 50 move rule will become very uh
relevant
and okay a check White's King can go
pretty much anywhere I would go towards
your pawns just uh keep those pawns
protected ideally
I don't think there's any danger here
mostly Retreats not ideal now the white
king is cut off far away from the action
but it is a safe Square
better to do than another track
I would just keep the king exactly
where he's placed it Black's Queen is
inching closer but not really to any
Avail here it's not going to help the
winning attempts there's just no way to
get rid of White's Queen yeah yeah you
can't you really do need a coordinated
attempt and it does look like from
magnus's body language that he knows
it's a draw
well he knows his dog it's been a draw
for a long time he's just trying his
luck
yeah I mean the one thing I learned from
filming my chessable course on grinding
out end games with magnuses
um I think he even used the phrase he
said even if you know it's a draw play
till the end because uh in Practical
terms psychology is half the battle and
psychology here is key Wesley's very
strong very resilient but against maybe
less uh sure less confident end game
players Magnus might win the same game
and uh Queen exchange yeah nope the
answer is no a queen exchange would have
given black a past pawn and Black's king
would have been quick enough to run
forward but now Magnus has actually done
some small but potentially significant
things I mean take a look at the white
king it's on the bottom row if the black
king now were to start moving forward
maybe some chances we're in the winning
territory potentially yeah I mean if you
can just pick off one of those white
pawns that's his dream then two verses
one great winning chances
but uh yeah unfortunately it's the first
step the maybe the most problematic is
that it's hard to avoid Wesley's checks
instead Magnus his Queen was perfectly
placed he had to retreat her
and uh yeah she stepped back she blocked
her check she blocked another check
how come Wesley best place his Queen now
I think he's going to move it over to
the d8 square protect his pawns and also
prevent the black king from marching
forward yup he does the same just from
the center which uh is equally logical
yeah do we think we'll hit the 100 Mark
I think we will
it's 91. 91. good chances so I'm not
going to take that back David
you always win your back to your Banker
not for that one the Lannisters always
pay their debts but Ivanka always wins
her bets
and another offer of a queen exchange
again don't get tempted if you're Wesley
so Queen exchange would only help black
with a better Pawn structure
and another check we've almost been here
before
time time to advance the king
and now if the White Queen gives a check
the black queen can step back and
intercept it
and we'll see that happen yeah and
potentially Magnus has found a way to
activate the king
yeah if you can activate your king
you're playing with two pieces against
one white king will never be active if
you can activate the black king and
queen combine Them Together Jack
diagonal check now is the time you think
now that [ __ ] oh it doesn't come
forward he didn't take the opportunity
maybe it was possible for Magnus but
back you think you're disappointed yeah
because you know all the good work has
been undone by that move
what was the point uh okay maybe the
king is going to go to the edge of the
board and uh Wesley is relying on his
tried and testy method tested method of
defense and uh putting the queen on the
eighth row yeah
getting a big threat Wesley is
threatening Checkmate but Magnus will of
course see that or give some tricks
yeah the White Queen wants to go to h8
this is a check however
and uh how did the black king Escape
it's just trapped on the side can it
step forward now I mean with the idea
that if the queen were to give a check
black queen steps back really clever and
you have forced white screen into the
corner your black king is now looking
ready to capture some pawns but Wesley
again shuts the door says no you can't
take my pawns centralized defending from
the side
black screen now is on a bit of a bad
Square on a bit of a bad circuit
suddenly Magnus is risking something the
black king could get trapped on this
side big day big threat on the board
actually as well you know if black porn
sorry if the F Pawn steps forward
it would have been a self-made yeah we
can just show this on the board it's
never too late to blunder and while
Magnus continues trying to squeeze this
one out if he had been ambitious here
and pushed the spawn forward Ivanka
you're right I was actually going to say
maybe you can grab the poor next move
but suddenly a check from the bottom row
and the King only has one square whoops
Checkmate you're trapped on the edge of
the board so this is the problem for
Magnus any winning attempts come with
risk and uh let's go back to the
position it's this position right now
and uh yeah Wesley again he's closing
the door on the black king No Escape
squares sooner or later it will get
kicked back where it came from
reaching move a hundred in game two
there we are between these two they
played now for 65 minutes the other
matches have now started game threes
these two will have 10 minutes after
this game before game three starts for
them we're gonna jump into Prague Mama
Dr of game three which is a dramatic
situation for Prague sitting in San
Francisco he cannot lose that game if he
does he will lose the match
Magnus Carlson and Wesley so they are
tied after the first game and probably
after this game as well it's been a
dramatic one but it looks like Wesley
will be able
to save a draw while it was him that had
the advantage earlier in the game
but now Magnus he is pushing for that
win
typical Magnus Carlson exactly that's
how he's risen to the top of world chest
that's how he broke onto the scene
actually he wasn't necessarily
outplaying his opponents uh in the
middle game in the opening he had some
uh weaknesses there but he was dominant
in the end game ever since he was a
teenager
unfortunately he's met his match in this
one Wesley is gonna hold this one very
comfortably in the end and only 10 more
moves now before we hit the 50 move rule
the last Pawn was pushed on move 63 that
means move one one three is the golden
mark
where a game will be technically I mean
it'll just automatically be declared a
draw yeah the players have no choice I
mean the computers just say nope draw
and I really like the way that Wesley
has been defending this very calm
calculation and all the time he's just
mobilizing the queen just harassing the
black king and uh there you see Magnus
put his Queen on the corner of the ward
kiss a check intercepts nothing much has
changed
yeah nothing much much has changed at
all and he's running out of time only a
few more moves now a handful of moves
105
yeah unless I was going to say unless
you could push your Blackboard on that
move or the move before no chance in
Wesley preventing any pawn pushes if I
were Wesley here I would just plant the
White Queen in front of that black
f-bone and say you're not going to move
that we're five minutes away from the 50
move rule
and he should be aware the players can
see the move count uh on their screen
okay he gives a bunch of checks this is
equally viable getting closer to that
magical Mark and it's coming it's four
moves away ironically Magnus has made
quite a lot of progress in the last few
moves he's actually got his King out of
the corner into the center
so he's probably got the best position
he's had all end game but he's only got
three moves to make a pawn push or a
capture and there won't be time for that
Wesley can give a couple more checks get
closer to that magical mark
yeah here we go one more track
Magnus how to run away from this because
you know you only have how many
enemies now three really moves
Magnus is calculating blocking this
check with the black queen but no he
goes back and we'll see yeah
and yeah one more move
and unless I'm mistaken
maybe I am mistaken no but there we go
never mistaken David it's a draw after
113 moves uh Wesley so fought